à la 5 ans et blanches 8 ans vont passer
une partie des vacances d'été ensemble
elles sont déjà copine une complicité
née de leur rencontre
séka séka roger les chiens et qu'elle
avait pas les chiens et bien fraîche
avec l'affairé une centaine d'enfants
une vingtaine de familles vont
bénéficier comme à la des dispositifs
proposés par le secours populaire
objectif permettre aux plus précaires de
partir en vacances
en fait le constat c'est qu'il ya
toujours un français sur trois qui
partent pas en vacances donc nous à
notre niveau on prétend pas résoudre le
problème du non départ mais au moins
manifester notre solidarité en premier
vis-à-vis des familles que l'on connaît
par le biais des réseaux des deux
permanences d'accueil jusqu'au peu
claires sur le département
sophie gré elle s'est inscrite au
dispositif copains des vacances elle va
accueillir à la pendant deux semaines
avec un programme déjà bien remplie dès
mercredi après demain nous allons
prendre le train pour descendre chez mes
beaux parents qui habitent dans le sud
de la france
on va rester là bas une semaine après on
va rentrer chez nous du côté de
rambouillet là on habite à la campagne
et puis on va être à la maison faire des
activités de promenade en forêt
ça fait plaisir pour des enfants pour
aller en vacances avec sa copine et moi
j'ai dit c'est avec ce qu'on pouvait
dire cg non parole de la mer le 20
juillet encore avec la petite famille
pour passer en journée et c'est le
moment des au revoir la fille de jama
part avec sa nouvelle copine direction
sa maison à la boissière l'école pour
retrouver les chiens de blanche